black et merci d'être avec nous sur
france 3 centre val de loire la matinale
et pour présenter votre dernier album
éternel insatisfait
c'est comme ça vous qualifier c'est que
vous savez que je me qualifie c'est
comme ça que je qualifie l'être humain
en général les images en tête pour dire
que j'en veux toujours plus l'être
humain en général on veut plus en plus
et voilà c'est un éternel
alors dans ce deuxième album solo fait
appel à d'autres rappeurs français
notamment soprano que j'ai aussi
interviewé ici même il ya quelques
semaines le rap français c'est une
grande famille n'y a pas de concurrence
entre vous ça dépend pour qui
pour ma part comme quelqu'un comme
soprano
oui c'est une famille c'est une famille
parce qu'on a beaucoup de points communs
on n'est pas les seuls et à de trappeur
aussi qui ont pas mal de grands que moi
nous y a pas de clash entre eux
quels sont les rappeurs qui ont marqué
votre parcours votre carrière
arias en appelant moi j'écoutais beau
pas mal de rap français
quasiment tous tous nos quelques noms
quand même
ntm iam secteur enfin tout ce qui a
marqué les marques et les box alliant
les années 80 90 2000
mais en quoi que justement la rade que
vous faites est aujourd'hui il différent
de celui qu'on a connu dans ces années
là et que l'on entend plus aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui est différent c'est les
sonorités le message
[Musique]
voilà c'est de l'évolution en fait la
musique elle veut pas rester toujours
toujours la même
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui c'est une autre époque on
est dans autre chose c'est plus les
mêmes codes
à l'époque il n'avait pas les réseaux
sociaux et un super g c'est la chat etc
aujourd'hui c'est autre chose c'est de
nouveau code alors cette partie du
groupe sexion d'assaut aujourd'hui vous
êtes en carrière solo comment vous vivez
cette carrière c'est différent c'est pas
la même approche avec le public sur
scène c'est sûr que c'est pas la même
approche mon public est un peu différent
du public de la sexion d'assaut j'ai un
public très familial
même si section en inverse aussi mais
voilà moi c'est différent il ya beaucoup
plus de jeunes qui m'écoutent section
c'était plus notre génération anneaux
donc ouais c'est notre approche à ce que
les rencontres que vous faites avec ce
public vous inspire dans l'écriture de
vos chansons
bien sûr parce que quand on voit
beaucoup de jeunes dans le public on a
quelque part 1 1 comme un rôle de grand
frère
et voilà ça inspire à dire des belles
choses de raconter comment j'ai réussi à
faire tout ça si ça peut motiver les
plus jeunes
je suis là pour ça alors votre carrière
solo prend une autre dimension à ces
derniers puisque shakira vous a fait
confiance sur son nouvel opus eldorado
avec le titre comme moi comment vous
avez approché cette star internationale
c'était pour vous
la concrétisation d'un rêve c'est
clairement un rêve de de se retrouver
sur un morceau avec shakira est encore
pire de se retrouver à faire un clip
avec shakira est encore pire de se
retrouver sur l'album de shakira ouais
c'est clairement un rêve qui se
concrétise
je suis très fier de ça j'ai même pas de
mots et je n'aurais même pas à décrire
ce qui s'est passé alors on voit là
derrière on va structurer un petit peu
au mois sept scènes avec votre concert
qui va commencer dans quelques instants
qu'est ce qu'un jour vous avez l'espoir
de le dire shakira sera avec moi aussi
dans un zénith pour pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas à paris pourquoi paris je
vois c'est peut-être en préparation mais
d'être on sait rien négocié avec l oms
est pas là je n'en dirai bob lee
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
matinale de france 3 centre val de loire
et puis un franc succès à votre tournée
2010 est sans merci beaucoup